the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess club
[Music]
hello everyone and thank you for joining
us we are in the championship round for
these summer chess Classics I'm Yasser
along with David hi everyone that is
crazy it's over before it started what's
going on it's been exciting and it's
been a lot of fun and the fight that
very top is incredibly intense as our
standings will show us do the honors
tell us about the standings for group
okay absolutely like stunning situation
we have four-way tie Benjamin book
ramnak satwani John Burke Nichols
Theodore our time for First with five
points that is intense and in the B
group
bigger looks better because we only have
two-way tie here with Simeon lamassov
and Andrea Hong five and a half points
and also Andrew just finished his game
and he drew against Brandon Jacobson who
played the second half of the tournament
very decently I think it's a solid
result for Andrew but right it means
that Simeon lamasov can't take the
championship exactly are man still in
the mix there uh as he's a tied for
third alongside actually tell us about
the as we see the playing Hall very nice
view of the playing Hall tell us about
the tournament format how does it work
it's two template around Robin nine
minutes for the first 40 moves 30
minutes for the rest of the game and 30
seconds increment throughout the game
exactly well we will be crowning a
champion today regardless of whether
they tie for first what happens in case
of a playoff
in case of a playoff if it's only two
players will have ten plus two rapid
match okay ten plus two please notice
it's delayed and not an increment bonus
the clock doesn't start for the first
two seconds and if those games are still
uh tied if the games are still tied
after the rapid matches we are gonna
immediately have Armageddon game okay
this is a little confusing if there's
more players uh hopefully that's a
bridge we'll cross to uh once we get
there but jump into the pairings with me
just tell me what what our viewers can
expect of today's Championship round in
the a group please last round pairings
are insane we only have gems so I love
this tournament but our key matchup for
the group a is hakapian versus Benjamin
Bach well let's just jump into that game
because I gotta tell you uh Benjamin no
me gusta I do not like what Ben has done
in this game essentially uh White
sacrificed upon a very nice strategic
sacrifice because he's got domination of
the position and the extra Pawn is not
meaningful over here on the queen side
in the meantime all of the pieces the
black pieces are all stuck and what
um Aaron did was very nicely he
continued it must be strategically
winning for a while absolutely yeah and
he white is threatening you know either
to reposition his Queen to go to G6 or
to more simply just shake things up on
the king side with G4 and H5 so this
position uh the current game position I
have to tell you it looks in my eyes
dreadful for one of our tournament
leaders for the first time Aram looks
happy Yeah and I don't blame it because
he's got a great situation and tell us
about the pairings in the group b Group
B we have important matches today and as
also we also mentioned Andrew Hong made
a draw already versus Brandon Jacobson
and key matchup for this round is La
Masa versus michelian
mikelian Oram is just
behind the Semion and then here you can
see that it depends what kind of result
and who's going to grab the leadership
so if you don't have five and a half
points and then Armand has
Five Points and just behind that well
that's interesting as we take a look at
the line score let's take a look at the
position there uh it it's kind of a very
strange looking position to my eyes
because we've got a dragon Not Unusual
there with both sides of Castle and
short but somehow the a file is open
normally in a dragon I'm used to seeing
the pawns on A7 and B7 kind of hard to
open up the a file when the upon
something said in this particular
position I do feel that whites for
choice I mean a lot of action is going
on on the queen side it moves like Rook
A4 and Rook A1 I would find natural for
the first player and I just feel like
they just want to move E5 and Knight B3
I believe happens white has to be for
choice and you said E5 was his pipe so
let's play the E5 and Knight B3 was
played by
on myself right very quickly no it
changed the position totally right the
structure is different and most probably
black has to push D5 exactly
um
I'm just looking at some tactical
sequence of it looks like a massively
confused moment here Knight C2 is also
possible yeah sir sorry at what moment
can I play Knight C2 yes
Bishop text my texts
[Music]
it takes on B3
I kind of lost count I mean I feel like
we're playing a game of suicide joke
because you're attacking on a f8
unfortunately ah I got you there on that
one
um yeah it's suddenly be the move E5 uh
kind of created this violence
yeah Meister Chico a strategic battle
he want he wants to sacrifice the pawn
on B6 and maybe take on B5 and then play
D5 if you take on B6 just read the
something not business yeah something of
the because black has it and now if you
take it then Rook C8 as possible sure
Rook C8 and now we cannot play C3
because Knight D3 I have a double attack
that's a nice Fork that's for sure the
desirable Bishop C5 could walk into
Queen takes and that's two pieces for a
rook and maybe black is for choice in
that situation I do believe black
will equalize
um the players have been fighting Hard
Eight really really great combative
rounds today the ninth tell us what
they're fighting for let's start with
the a group
players are fighting for uh great prizes
actually first place is six thousand
dollars second place is four thousand
dollars and third place is three
thousand dollars for the group a and
then rest of the players are gonna get
some nice prizes as well and total price
point of the tournament is twenty two
thousand dollars nice and uh for the B
group for the B group first place is
four thousand second place is two and a
half thousand and third place is two
thousand dollars with the total price uh
font of fourteen thousand dollars and
everyone in the tournament will get some
nice prizes as well thank you St Louis
chess club and as we prepare as we're
beginning our broadcast a few games have
already uh been completed uh two draws
in this group here I want to just take a
quick Gander the game between Andrew
Brandon again this game has already been
drawn
groomfield groomfield player I do yeah
with black yes are you big it's funny
how H4
uh uh our H4 has taken over in some of
these we talked about it yesterday day
you remember h4a4 moves
check this out this is like this is
going to be a crazy game now whenever I
see completely crazy and we're gonna see
completely crazy let me assure you I
have the impression that it's
preparation like these guys know what
they're doing it seems like both of them
I think in Broomfield it's important to
know your lines oh you're playing it you
better know it absolutely so this one uh
be prepared Queen D5 check that has been
blocked
here's what I was saying about crazy if
you take the Rook the Knight G5 check
and queen takes G4 it has a lot of
like yes
session there and the players by the way
quickly reached this position before
they even started to slow down so again
all preparation all craziness but
nonetheless preparation checks I know
and look at this should we try to cancel
it
this is just this is what you would just
call you know prep and amazing prep at
that by the way check that move out
Queen f8 uh just pinning like being
stubborn I don't want to make my night
there he goes Knight takes E5 and check
this out bang again uh spectacular yes
but still I would say in the player's
preparation including up to the move C3
and Knight takes E4 yeah
I do not know this line but again I have
just seen so many of the players like
just
everything just gets like uh two
generations I know exactly check they've
got their chess engines man they figured
it all out Queen F3 chess is easy check
check if you check on Asics for Cafe it
is coming that's why you gotta move your
cane but that's still a lot of pieces
for the queen right absolutely Queen E4
now we've got uh I have our own Trump if
you take the Rook then take the bishop
on A6 the problem is that your King has
no squares to hide and then slowly I'm
gonna check check and it it is all the
pieces Jack Jack and yeah there's no
good defense uh other than check like
Perpetual because I'm attacking on G6
on that night
otherwise yeah you better take the
Perpetual at this point by the way I'm
gonna break away from uh the draws
because we have a decisive name when we
came in we said a marquee matchup had to
be one of our tournament co-leaders
Benjamin bogg and he was up against Aram
who had drawn on all of his games so he
didn't expect to suddenly be in a
situation that he was losing but by the
time the players reached this position I
think Benjamin had just suddenly come to
the realization that his position's
terrible also you got a note that look
at the time auram has one hour but in
versus three minutes yeah it means it
was a preparation did preparation for a
very very nice preparation by Airmen for
Benjamin this moves Max of desperation
and unfortunately for Benjamin there's a
beautiful
um tactical shot right here you take
giving away The Rook please take my Rook
discovered check
attacks the queen and when you put the
queen back in the way the old check
and the queen is left unprotected after
the king is forced to move so you can't
take the Rook now you've got to move the
queen uh by the way I was thinking that
he was going to take as well because you
still have it this is nice yeah sir
today we're in shape we are not missing
this move no no this is really nice this
is actually very beautiful uh shot E6
discover check you're breaking down uh
these two pawns that are are shielding
Black's King and wow here it's just like
witch
what move doesn't when Suddenly at this
point takes
oh takes
finally this move C5 too little too late
check
is that double check mate it is a
Checkmate well it's a beautiful
Checkmate but it's a double check that
is insane so I think I only occurred in
my games once where I gave Checkmate to
my opponent which was a double
Checkmate and in this case the bishop as
well as the Rook are at Target very cute
fantastic fortunate for a book who was
leading the tournament and most probably
he's not gonna tie anymore for the first
well that is certainly not going to
happen nope as he uh goes out
um while we're on in this tournament
we'll take a look at two the games that
were drawn ranu he came in today's round
also tied for the First with Benjamin
Bach he was up against but he decided to
play safer than me and also didn't
fortunately for him didn't walk into
preparation that is for sure uh
this whole line I have seen
oh Alexander onishook playing it as uh
black in multiple games and somehow he
always defends it I always find it
awkward to play the Black side of this
uh particular line I like playing Black
side do you this one yeah it for for me
I I don't have a a good feeling uh
almost got like winning position the
problem with this position that you feel
like oh finally I'm pressing not equal
and then it has its own like white has
its own weaknesses right A5 Pawn usually
drops and the problem is that sometimes
why it has enough to make a dragon
without a pawn
active active position right the double
Rooks the two Rooks on the open file uh
pressing against the pawn on C7 by the
way which is nicely protected not once
not twice but Thrice and uh wow okay the
players kind of reached their maximum
and then they Shuffle back with it they
decide that it's enough for us exactly
today uh ilionek he did not achieve what
he wanted uh all draws he instead
they're almost lost yesterday and the
irony uh of his game yesterday all the
games were drawn except for his game
which he loves and he's getting up to
that moment uh uh drawn all of his games
and today he drew his eighth out of nine
and his game with John Burke well there
was just not much into this game by the
way let's go back to the other group
because we have another decisive
yeah played the scotch so it goes to
show that elshon was in a very fighting
uh combative move Knight D2 a major
major move uh in in this uh very I want
to say topical Scotch the scotch is
about a hundred and well maybe closer to
200 years old
it is a tricky move but the problem is
that if black knows everything equalizes
easily well yeah well equally easily is
tough c2c4 is a major move here uh
Knight D2 is obviously a key alternative
the crazy part about this night on going
to D2 and why I've always avoided this
as white is usually it's about this
night so C4 Knight B6 is a major move C4
Bishop A6 is a major move and the whole
idea is you want to drive the Knight to
V6 whether or not you're losing after
that that's a different or worse it
doesn't matter but that's the whole
purpose of this line of the scotch when
you play the move Knight D2 in the and
again the reason why I've always shy
away from this is because of this move
Knight F4 your Bishop is temporarily
blocked and it doesn't matter it's a
nice sleeve still yeah and the Knight
finds a better Square on E6 as you're
ready to go Queen to B4 but okay let's
see what happened Knight to D2 Queen E6
Knight to F3 Bishop C5 all of this is
very very standard stuff white has
achieved what he wants by the way which
was to drive the Knight to the B6 Square
now he's hoping that with the move
Knight G5 and maybe a little tickle you
know the the queen will get find itself
boxed then
G3 H5
I like this idea a4fa4 which is a very
typical after night bt2
yeah but this is well okay hold on this
is like a it's a very strange thing that
white is doing uh
normally how do you say uh there are
there are zones there are sectors there
are that there are areas where you play
and there's areas where I play so for
example you have a majority on the queen
side half majority on the king side you
get to play on your majority I get to
play on life look at what where is White
playing
in this game White's playing in the
center
he's playing on the queen side but he's
also playing on the king side in other
words he's spread his forces really
thinly because it's sort of like he
wants to control the entirety of the
board the problem is this position is
that yeah you're playing in everywhere
it feels like you're active everywhere
but
those are weaknesses yeah sure I put my
Pawn on A4 which is great which means it
creates C4 Fitness already and Rook H4
is an actual protecting C4 exactly
exactly it's more of a defensive okay
let's see how how the here we go
whoa Okay so
the idea behind Rook takes C4 D5 exactly
D5 I think elshon just missed it and
then check and uh
exactly black picks up the exchange so
we can't take there so Knight takes C4
so Bishop takes H6 well in for a penny
in for a pound is that sacrifice even I
mean if I play Knight E3 for example 93
maybe bishop to D3 but I I hear you loud
and clear because that's like one of
those I have five
impossible I I'm not saying it's the
exactly well guess what you you from
your lips to his uh teammates whoa
Queen if that's the best what do you
think if that's the best something is
wrong right 92 is possible as well I
need you to check that was what elshon
didn't like so he decided
he he he ends up uh sacrificing his
Queen does elshon but no
crazy crazy wild game oh yes we have a
guest in studio Vegas
oh yeah lunch baby
okay we're waiting to look at to show up
now you can see the players and we have
two more round two more games through
mining in group a let's take a look
to akshat's game it feels like
white is doing good
um actually this King seems very weak
and Knight on H5 is great and queen is
attacking
I like bachelorette's position more now
we have Luca in the city hi Hi how are
you doing well doing good after a win
yeah finally it's a good feeling to
finish the tournament with a win right
yeah I've always got to finish with the
win it's back to 50 percent yeah and
today's game was kind of interesting and
it feels like it was easier I mean not
necessarily is it it was pretty
complicated game from the beginning can
you explain what happened it feels like
this all our Theory
I mean it is probably Theory but not
well known at least not to us I guess
like robots playing out of head
I saw you were spending a lot of time uh
was 92 I mean he doesn't play Scotch at
all so you didn't prepare at all yeah
yeah okay season 92 is it's kind of a
rare move but I do understand remember
we have some idea like A4 A5 A4 as well
I don't know I forgot so my idea was to
play Queen E6 so I can develop my Bishop
also and just develop my pieces and then
see what happens weren't you afraid that
you can kind I don't think that should
be dangerous because he can never really
play 94 because Pawn is hanging it's
always hanging right yeah it looked good
after Bishop C5 I think actually the
line goes instead of Knight F3
that there's some C4 move here so like
C4 and Knight B4
and then something like Knight fifty
Queen G6 I think 93.6 but I might be
wrong
because it didn't really check it today
at all should I play King D1 just I
actually think that might be the line
yeah but like I played some games as
well oh yeah like American Cup right I'm
not sure I'm not gonna tell you right
okay
so so C4 okay very logical it feels like
white is doing all the logical moves and
actually white is pushing and usually if
you put your Pawn in H5 and develop your
Rook you should be fine in such
positions right well the thing is that
I'm pretty fast with my development and
if I can somehow develop attack on his
C4 Pawn yeah then that's going to be my
counter play and I can also get in
trouble like what happened in the game
pretty much yeah I was thinking of H5
instead of G3 H5 if you play Bishop A6
or H4 then can you take I okay I don't
remember exactly but maybe diff d5r D5
is my idea in most positions D5 yeah
it's weird to look at the position from
right angle to be honest so
okay if you take I think I'm games are
fine for me like I can always just take
take cd6
it's pretty pretty equalish equals I can
Castle I actually like the position for
black even like all the end games
because I'm gonna push D5 at the moment
maybe this is their active and he's
usually in his coach whenever you
exchange yeah exactly should be it
should be dangerous for me absolutely so
he chose to play G3
yeah I was like
I can play Bishop A6 first but then B3
and now A4 I'm not even having any
concrete threats now because even ABAB
Bishop C4 is not a chat because my rock
is playing yeah so we need to Castle
first and only that even have a minor
thread so like I felt like A4 should be
the best move
because I mean he can still not develop
his Bishop from F1 obviously because
Pawn is hanging they are behind
development first yeah exactly that was
my point and I'm curious would you
consider Rook B1 yeah everyone is
actually one of the most I thought about
but like I usually have maybe bishop A6
first no B3 and now I have Queen g6's
idea like I don't know whether I'll play
it here this is hanging right yeah
probably and then we play this end game
most probably it's the best that white
can do because I felt like after G3 he's
already late yes you are developing
faster and A4 is a massive straight
Bishop A6 and if you're not on time to
actually solidify C4 Pawn you should be
better yeah what you're saying makes a
lot of sense because endgame with the
pawn on E5 seems better for white like
only if I manage to exchange epon for
like fancy seven or something like that
um that's quite like equal at least for
black
yeah H5 almost waiting for I thought
he's gonna play H5 or
see this G3 looks weird right isn't it
like I mean he wants to play he has to
develop Bishop somewhere so like show
Basics it's pretty large this is all
seems logical and then it feels like
here
white should be fine I mean actually a
few moves back
so
yeah now I have two options one is to
play F5 yeah wants to play Queen E7
okay so Queen E7 I have a point of
missing my thread not yet but my idea is
gonna be what happened in the game but
just taking here yeah well F5 is also
threatening that but it's even more
concrete can I just take it no if you
take it I like the Android plastic and
then this must be great exactly and
um or even like just take on F6 because
you cannot even defend the the C4 plan
and I should probably play like this is
nice yeah but I like this this is stuck
here
but like
I don't remember what I was afraid of
exactly here but there was like
but then I can take on C4 with both
maybe it would be better for me to play
Rook F4 and yeah that was actually yeah
Rook before and now G4 this is strong I
probably wouldn't take but like I can
obviously if I take on C4 and he takes
on F5 that can that can get dangerous
for me
okay actually yeah not in this position
the idea whole idea is yeah okay but
Queen E7 seems very solid yeah but now
after I thought I'm already chatting in
94 but here actually after 94 Rook C4 D5
white has Rook A4
and now I'm just lost
that's not legal unfortunately because
Bishop so I'm just lost and that's why
black has to play and we just take it
yeah two pieces that so
this Remains the motivation for that
reason to protect your Rook I know it's
again a threat no before five
obviously caught me by surprise I was
like okay what's his idea yeah he told
me like instead of Bishop D2
that um he went to play Bishop 5
immediately after Queen
and then his idea is to play Bishop D3
and then protect C4 Pawn yeah pretty
much but it is seems like very logical
after Castle Bishop F5 now he's
threatening to protect the pawn and it
seems like Bishop D3 Queen E4 as long as
I put this position it's very dangerous
for me obviously but there is 94.
was it a blunder well yeah he also
thoughts
because of this line
it feels like he just plundered Knight
C4 and this is the best try he has
mostly right I felt it's more we are not
using the engine but like it's out of
desperation I feel like he's tilted a
little bit as well is objectively the
best option because now but I have to
play D5 or 92 or 92 I would play
probably it's just very simple way to
keep the pawn now Queen B2 I think
everything else is on the spot somehow
loses one more Pawn yeah so yeah
and now I wasn't sure what to do but
like I'm pulling up yeah D6 exactly I
mean the problem is that King doesn't
have any squares one's one up I'm gonna
grab another one it just looks so good
it's lost yeah so so he tried Bishop's
h65 was a blunder because like
absolutely if he doesn't play Bishop
profile but like Roxy one mm-hmm
that's fine position like it it's a
player it's a game right yeah I'll play
some D5
so it was a huge blunder by elshon and
how do you feel about the tournament in
general okay well obviously it didn't
start very very well as the last first
two games but managed to bounce back so
I'm happy with my finish great and
congratulations and good luck with the
rest of your tournaments that's coming
up and I know and good luck thanks again
I'll see you soon
so let's check Simeon lamassov versus
Arman mikalian game
it's a very crucial game for Simeon
because if he wins the game he's
grabbing the championship he's grabbing
the first place and so far
he I like his position he seems he's
doing fine it seems he's doing fine if
Bishop D6
then Rook d8 maybe even E5 is great move
I like how night can come to D6 or works
A7 and A1 I have a feeling he's gonna
grab the game this is a very Grim I
would say
foreign
but it's not looking good let's take a
look what happened right oh so he did
play
Bishop B5 as we talked about but not D5
but the Rook C8 first but I would prefer
D5 if you wanna if you are taking it
yeah then I can play Rook seed it's a
totally different situation it must have
been a he must have been afraid of Rook
A4 that must have been because like you
say if you get in Bishop B6 Rook C8
you're a happy camper you're you're
threatening C2 it's not so convenient
but I think it was Rook a for that
person I wonder if I can sacrifice
something see the beautiful thing and
this is the advantage right here right
now of being a commentator yeah
it was played and rookie C1 I'm
protecting because like and the pawn I
cannot play C3 is set because of my day
three so this is pretty much only milk
now D5 was played Queen D2 give me the
night uh this is
D4 nine I do not like all this idea see
if my Rook was on d8 yes it was
protecting D5 now it's not maybe it was
it wasn't such a bright idea actually to
play roxy85 it was all the consequences
at D5 E5 kind of once you play E5 you
need to play D5 yeah if you don't play
D5 one time after usually after C4 Queen
D2 C4 you suffer forever exactly so it
was all a kind of a consequence one
thing might do another and maybe just
Overlook the strength Bishop F4 I have a
feeling he looked overlooked Rook a for
idea earlier he probably his plan was to
play D5 but he forgot that after Rook
before he doesn't have a good Square to
retreat with the Knight exactly exactly
so things are now working out very
nicely for white and after Bishop F4
lamasov is looking great here Queen
takes sweet f96
then we can play Queen C7
well even that it still looks excuse me
very good for white
if I play this you're protecting the
bishop F4 I cannot take it no
thank you the players have just played
some moves uh but Queen takes yeah so
are you missing something after Knight
D6 there should be a move
probably we are what could be uh what
could be clever maybe Queen E7
so yeah
if you take the
rookies right and if you take on B4 then
something like maybe Knight H5 might H5
and then die this should be five maybe
Rook C6 I wouldn't say I wouldn't say
I'm a happy camper by the way vegan I I
think it's not going crazy
this is not a good good situation for
black but I think that Knight D6 is not
going away either like the game
continuation
yeah still looks pretty good for white
and then Bishop let's see let's update
the position well I was playing he
played Bishop D2 I do not I'm a fan of
this move I do not like Bishop only two
yeah so we talked about it like
how Bishop can be very useful in the
center in general right like controlling
all this diagnosis sure now Bishop is
not doing much probably the idea of
Bishop did is to go back the Shabbat
before well protects the queen and maybe
in this particular case uh samyon was
thinking that he doesn't need the bishop
to win the game he wants to play Rook A7
absolutely wants to play Rook A7 and
maybe on a good day you know drop the
queen and by the way Knight D6 is still
on tap so let's see what happened went
to d8 and that's it is
let's count the pawns yeah sir I like
lions count whites it seems like why it
has more yes and more is good uh white
White's doing really really well and for
Semion is he comes into this round type
for first right yeah he doesn't have
focused and then a little bit nervous he
is yeah you're definitely drilling
that's a little bit of excitement of uh
winning you know absolutely uh
especially uh these Championship rounds
it brings out the best so we think
samion's doing very good let's just jump
to the game of action I do not like
akshat's position that's we I touched it
a little bit but you did yeah
Bishops I love Knight on H5 I love Queen
on C2 and then now he's opening up CVC
file maybe even this I know I'm hanging
F2 admit but like
maybe even this is great for me what I'm
still I'm still reeling from the body
count so continue the line rookie seven
most probably you have to take right
okay should I exchange or should I play
C1 okay
um
Bishop B7 it should be someone just to
remind you you guys you've got a king as
well I mean there is a I can't take okay
and again what's a body count uh still
have some pawns I know you have many
pawns I did F2 I I was nice to you as
well all right well thank you so uh
worst case I can just take on V7 play
Rook F1 when if you take Uncle we need
to clean E4 it's going F4 and I'm
controlling the square so far
I feel like your king is weaker than
mine I I don't know why I have this
feeling but it feels like you've got
control the control of the f file and
then I'm threatening your rookie a
G1 and my knight so it's so cute on age
five uh crazy line uh that you just
showed there Vegas most probably there
are many more nicer things for example
Queen A4 right and just I just wanted to
see how they got here okay Queen takes
D6 takes takes so this is a so Queen A4
very attractive looking move that's a
Tempo and you you you're hitting the
Rook right so Queen A4 is one move what
did you just play Queen Bee one was the
what was the line where maybe I was
being a little too greedy maybe I'll
just
I don't know go back and just uh you
still have to yeah so you cannot go back
I know no Retreats no Retreats uh no no
no fun uh the queen A4 is certainly a
very forcing but you still can't believe
Queen isaban okay it feels like your
position should fall apart but it's not
it should it should uh falling apart I
don't know I still I I kind of like uh
sorry Bishop David seven yes
and I was going to go Bishop to C6 so in
case you take I wasn't sure if to take
with the queen or The Rook but I was
kind of some some you know harmonic
convergence going on over here that uh
actually I have a feeling that Bishop on
G2 is great but at the same time it's
kind of he took on C5 boring very boring
we don't want to see this uh we're not
playing for a pawn a lousy pond
wow yeah that's a good point uh he sorry
I'm just doing a refresh yes uh and he
took the pawn or he did he took the
queen and it's not been really late
sorry he did take it yeah we can see it
on on the camera she's there yeah and
then he just took the Palm okay
apparently he's a pawn Grabber too oh
congratulations we'll make sure he gets
his gold card and a membership to the
pond grubbers Association a very stately
and very proud Association I'll never be
part of it
we are accepting all members by the way
if you're having a a golden golden
jubilee uh Rook takes C5 okay I agree it
may not be any everybody's taste but at
the end of the day maybe whites for
choice because he'll play Rook A5 he's
got
you know he's kind of aiming over here
still he has some attack it's not like
if you don't have Queens you cannot
attack right for example you cannot
activate your Rook uh like you would be
too yeah because Rook 7 is a threat and
now you cannot play rookie seven because
your Bishops on C8 is hanging oops
otherwise you're losing your A7 Pawn
you're not on time if you do that yikes
yikes don't go there so you're right
some pressure for white so once so
what's that application but I I can
understand what surans
um philosophy when it comes to this
position he's like why should I risk
right let my opponent to find have to
defend this position it's not pleasant
and by the way Simeon has done precisely
what we thought uh you know he put his
Rook on the seventh rank we know that
such a a marvelous uh joyful idea he
also just dropped in with this queen
that freezes this and we're upon up yes
and queen he's threatening to checkmate
Black's Queen I have a huge problem with
his Bishop D2 idea why are you playing
ship D2 you might just be winning the
position that's right I don't know can I
play Bishop E5 I'm thinking of Queen G3
but then you're on time you're playing
Queen G5 right E5 now I want to play
Bishop E5
it feels like imagine having this
position with white but you're Bishop on
H2
well then uh yeah wouldn't we even like
uh under under guard uh just a second
I'm just having a thought that uh
what is my Rook doing on C1 I'm not a
hundred percent sure I like The Rook on
C when I'm looking okay
um
may I just ask the question check
I I think I'm happy to sacrifice my
Exchange
yeah well guess what you should be
you're gonna have no choice can I play
Knight G3 yes uh my intention was to
walk the plank across just take on e4
would it work Knight E4 again the joy of
commentating is that these aren't our
pieces
they're uh I'm trying my best I know to
unnerve me I know create some game
uh so far
right yeah the bishop was like on some
you know more aggressive Square on H2
it's more or less in the way oh I should
be more smarter about this position okay
93 yeah yeah Rook d e eight Rook David
E8
okay
is trying to mate me Knight F5 check
meet you
Knight H5 is an option by the way I'm
just saying that that you could you
could you have two ways of dealing with
the threat okay so you want to come down
right okay
Queen G3 please play
please
1993 oh I'm doing great yes or here
Queen G2 okay I just can't and I I just
can't take on a f8 probably
uh
to to me beg him yeah this position is a
complete a mess I mean I don't know how
we did it but we achieved I'm trying
success we got Chaos on the board
probably Knight H5 would be like
objectively better not to give away
stuff but but okay I mean we can do it
we have license that's when we get the
big bucks they put us together and they
say okay come on make make the magic
yeah our point is that it's not easy and
my point is that I just don't like
Bishop D2 I don't think you should leave
your king exposed exposed like that I
think Bishop was protecting all the
squares no it's not doing let's just
remind everyone however if Semion wins
he wins the term absolutely that's it
boom he's got it in the bag as uh
akshat's result would not be
um crucial because he will be half a
point ahead of everyone and and also
Andrew Hong drew his game already right
now if he has six points and if action
twins even like even though his position
doesn't look like painting even if he
wins it means he will have always he sex
points as well
means six and a half I gotcha uh the
move Knight
F4 was played I just don't like it too
when you're attacking you don't exchange
the Knight what
oh you you think no I'm not no I was
thinking so so I was looking at some
very forced line if I walked the plank
yeah right for example Rook here you've
got to play Knight E2 check I think his
idea is just to take a night night
yes uh
I was thinking
um you have to go 92 and in this case 93
is also possible right right you still
drop in I don't like which version is
better I feel like grabbing a pawn is
better sure so Knight f4 on the board
with the idea of munch and let's see
what can white do
um in this position you know I I really
despise this idea that the uh Queen may
show up on my doorstep something like
Queen G3 you know your knight H3 your
night oh 92. sorry it comes with the
yeah by the way earlier yeah I forgot so
in that case uh sadly if I'm required
then see one is he literally mentioned I
don't like my rookon Sequel and I don't
like the bishop on H2 but I love the
bishop on E5 a moment ago we had the
Bishop in this very awkward Square H2
but the bishop on E5 supporting the
queen that's a big so in this moment
that's why I don't like whole idea of
his Bishop D2 why would you give the
queen perfect square yeah
perfectly okay so just a second so
samion's got to do something here
maybe King F2 he would think of King F1
or King if king after Knight H3 so maybe
can you have one maybe that's a little
bit more uh then I can play actually D3
is it a threat Rook C7 or queen say
salmon
D3 Rook C7 or quick C7 there is
hanging
it's a mess it's another math it's
another mess but I do
I do believe we should consider after
King F1
with different notes yeah sir
I should have some moves here well King
F1 is designed to stop the fork as well
as to
lessen the impact a move like Knight
takes H3 doesn't come with check and
maybe I could then trade the Queens he
played it looks like Rook F1
okay that's a very
liking everyone for something I know it
was like
but okay he's saying if you go check
I'll go King F2 oh boy he's bringing his
Rook to
into the fans yeah into the defense yeah
Rook to F1 but here black
I don't know he's offering a draw by the
way like because work of fun is a draw
offer if you take on H3 I take Queen G3
Queen H3 Etc that is for sure I do more
probably he's not intending to capture
but but I do not believe in this not
intending the capture thing
no you're Knights trapped Knight takes
H3
it's not sorry why isn't it trapped
let me think uh
Knight takes H3 King
H1 if I return to F4 your ideas to play
Queen's Salah possibly and also possibly
Rook B7 because remember you you're
probably going to have to play Queen E5
regardless no most probably I will go
Queen C8 what or queen e Queen C8
Ultra oh never mind yes sir I mean is
this your idea but it's not that great
idea you could play Knight D6 first
that that wouldn't work after 96. then
you're gonna have to sacrifice an
exchange it's a mess it's still still
one of those things where
you oh I'm not a sacrifier you're busy
signing yes yes yes still it's still a
complete mess going on in this game
let's just check in on the other
tournament uh this is to see what's
happened in that again
um Benjamin Bach went down uh to defeat
but
Nicholas Nicholas is in the driver's
seat if he were to win this game
no playoff no playoff Knight H5 and
after the move G6
we are in a situation where my gosh I'm
just looking these Bishops are going to
be so powerful must be winning for white
right
both of the players are great when it
comes to messy positions yeah
Nichols loves he oh he always tries to
find some tricks and then as we sell for
now even though he's only 16 he loves to
play and tactics tactics he he's a very
gifted player as well so I feel like
it's far from over even though it seems
like white is crushing it does it does
at the moment
um this whole Queen side uh obviously uh
White love to put his Queen uh on F6 so
anything like this is something
yeah I would really feel like uh I
cannot afford to play This Way
um but if I don't take on D5
um okay go ahead crush me just kill me
uh I mean take it right okay
so I mean I'm closing my eyes
um I'm not looking at my king queen F2
should be enough
Queen F2
uh because you want to go here right
oh
I I wanted to use this Pawn as a
description I can check on and like
pizza as well grabbing grabbing oh no no
no no no definitely uh
here you
um
Queen F6 right yes
it's all so bad as you mentioned you
hate pins but it's like it's not a pin
but you cannot really get out of it
right okay so Knight takes do you take
yeah okay so at least in this case it's
it's really awful a rookie one I'm sorry
David Juan okay uh
I have no tricky C4 is a is a threat I
don't think you have a yeah it's I I
mean everything that I I'm doing I'm
basing upon some some use I want to get
some use out of uh this Pawn on B2 it
feels like Nico's very close to win the
tournament could be that's what I
thought as we were coming into this game
that uh let me just refresh my board as
Mishra and darush are playing and he has
taken the pawn so he is inviting the
line that we rejected uh takes
and how much time I wonder players have
because it seems like Nico is
trying to find a move quickly
um it's not on our boards yeah let's
refresh it so we can see no I don't see
the time on the boards either that is
upsetting we don't have the time but
look how nervous Nico is like yeah well
you can see it okay he's looking at the
most direct Rook takes Knight takes Rook
to D1
so he's in his mind I this night is
pinned and he's ready to slurp upon
maybe he could do how about the slurping
right away Queen takes C4 so yeah
[Music]
so the the question is right here right
now it's funny that you have these
attractive options okay A5 we're okay
five I have a feeling everything is
winning and queen takes C4
so three very attractive I would I would
find Rook to D1 the most compelling
myself because I just love pinning my
opponent I would also love taking phones
yeah uh I wouldn't be surprised that
Queen takes C4 might also be a winning
move for white at this moment so Bishops
are very strong I am grabbing all of
your pawns and the Knights are not uh
like they cannot find a place like 97.95
is technically not possible exactly uh
but again the knights have no Outpost
put this Knight on D3 it's a different
story uh again you've talked I I've
spoken about this numerous times on our
broadcast is this idea that the knights
who Thrive under protection
I have a feeling from the way he played
he had just a few seconds left
yeah yeah he barely like made the move
oh
so we're guessing we're doing uh some
guesswork as far as the clocks are
concerned so Rook D1 and very quickly AC
sub almost played yeah defending the
night and now the question
takes on C4 so the problem is the
desirable Knight E3 he immediately
played rookie five yeah I think they are
in a huge time trouble we just don't
know it huh unfortunately we do not know
it okay
um both seemed very focused and rookie 5
actually is a great try sure you've got
to defend the night okay so let's see if
we can't just uh uh win this one can we
play Bishop F4
or queen D4 that was a question for me
was I was wondering
should I provoke F6 and then play Bishop
F4
that's nasty that's almost like you know
sometimes you see the orcas yeah and the
whale and the seals and sometimes the
orcas play with their food a little bit
the queen to D4 Queen C4 that seems like
a very very nice move uh not playing so
fast so maybe we're wrong about the time
trouble maybe it's just maybe their
nerves then
not sure I wish we uh we've got uh the
game of Mishra and darush let's just
jump in and see what happened here well
guess what
the darouche is two pawns down
oops just one yeah sir just one or is it
two one two three one two three one two
three one two three four
just one but
a nasty Pawn right yes I mean yeah so
many weaknesses E6 right I mean A7 G5
was hanging too exactly if you put the
pawns on F7 and G6 okay
but okay something but now you're upon
down and you're you're you're you're
struggling
should winning is taking the game today
yeah
this is how we won the pawn also bimani
didn't start the tournament that well
but at some point he started to score
and it's getting better yeah absolutely
unfortunately he needs to end the
tournament when it's getting better
right and back to uh the Nicholas game
uh for a moment because once again
Nicholas wins this game
he is going to be the champion of the
tournament here Rook E5 sorry so we were
looking at Queen D4 F6 Queen C4 take it
away begum what what how do you break
down the position for white I mean we
know White's in good
shape good shape uh but you know you
still got to win the game yeah I like
Queen D4 I like Bishop F4 I I do believe
many people moves are winning okay so
Queen D4 let me probably you need to
move away yeah and then I was thinking
of book E1
ah Rook he won you have a huge weakness
yeah sir I do I do uh I knew I was going
to have to play this move one day or uh
another I mean if you play this move any
day
expose my kids I can't even go back Rook
D1 and then Quincy four okay but then I
got out of the pin and I mean you know
if probably G5 would be a great try for
you then Quincy
[Music]
okay now you're now now wait a minute
wait a minute are you sure I'm uh
no no no all of your pieces are hanging
but they were hanging a moment ago and
now for the first time I actually feel
like I can do something
I I can um I can threaten a check and uh
Knight E3 check uh we we we we we let it
go we we let it slip away on what
happened in the game oh sorry let me
just uh refresh
Queen D4 was played I can see the queen
on the dark Square okay Queen D4 Queen
E7 was played most problem so we are not
that bad yeah sir no and then
interesting moves are coming queen A7 is
a very interesting move
yeah
and what was that line once again if we
go F6
so I could take this with a check right
yeah that looks nasty that looks winning
that looks winning because Knight takes
that's the pin Tech sex Rook E7 but G5
doesn't give anything because of the
yeah
yeah that's just uh
that's just great for for white of
course okay so because they miss playing
a rookie long
we're not getting an update
from us oops excuse me because is
looking at his opponents saying what do
you want to do
so we think from the from the uh
on the board F6 Bishop D5 is the middle
why didn't I play Bishop D5 again what
was my email
yeah I mean you were like the Orca there
enjoying the food so much you forgot to
eat yeah we just were talking about F6
this Quincy for idea yeah before D5 is
just winning that's
Bishop D5 Rook D5
rookie Savana
Rook D4 and Rook C7 is just winning a
piece exactly but probably G5 is the
move to try to play Rook D2 Rook B2 to
create some play peace is a piece this
is a piece I agree on that you know that
great line from Michael tal so Bobby
Fischer
was being contemptuous he played them he
played F6
he did play after
[Music]
nothing F6
your course is about to attack on day
five
he will never miss such moves
yep
okay
as we think Bishop takes D5 and Nicholas
is most probably winning the tournament
we have another guest as uh
well the man who couldn't be defeated
um we're gonna see you later bye bye as
I uh get um
get rml set up he played against
Benjamin Bach
and won a really really nice uh nice
game we're getting a set up in studio
here as
we're not getting
updated on that game of Nicholas which
could very easily decide the tournament
hi hey nice well done I mean
you uh spoiled in the words of Anish
Gary a nearly perfect result yeah I know
I know that people wanted me to make the
last draw as well but uh you know the
game went really well for me so yeah
absolutely I mean saving your Best For
Last this Championship round we thought
that you won a really wonderful game go
ahead and take us through it whatever
sure
um yeah so
um I usually never play castle in but I
know a lot about it as every single GM
has two it seems these days Everybody
Plays there
um
so this line is very common nowadays and
I think I played the same against
abhimanyu Mishra okay the same structure
actually
so all this is very common A3 and
yeah I had the same game till this point
yeah I went Knight bd7 which I believe
is the best move here
for black just to you know because if
white takes yeah if white takes on C6
they are like welcome yes exactly
because that's the weakness yeah yeah
and uh you kind of uh in the game a very
funny thing happened to Benjamin he kept
the weakness the whole time he just
defended it defended and then he had no
play yeah exactly that's the whole point
of this uh structure and uh before the
game I was thinking that if I go to this
position it would be a good choice
because Benjamin is known as someone who
always who is always in time travel yes
so I can easily keep playing and kind of
torture him you know exactly came here
yeah uh we came in the studio round
about this this part and I'm a pawn
Grabber I like I love being up upon this
is not one of my first loves this is a
position which I actually really kind of
despise uh for uh black because he's so
inactive exactly and you you can kind of
in a sense just what you did you
measured your opponent I think a lot of
people can really learn from your
approach uh
Drive the night away get the night out
of there yeah but all you're doing is
and we do have every Theodore uh our
congratulations Nicholas has one uh the
game and won the tournament but the move
E2 E4 is giving black everything he
wants suddenly he does have a counter
play so I really loved your patient
approach E3 and maybe you'll agree or
disagree uh with me well uh to be honest
the the moment when I went night before
I
I didn't know that night before is not a
bad move right because in this structure
the main point is that that you trade
the knights yes what happened in the
game and my whole point is that now I
want to go Bishop E4 and let's say at
some point and you know this is yeah
Bishop B1 and then Queen gets to the H7
Square exactly exactly black cannot
really stop it
yeah which is why I think Benjamin
played the move G6 in the game exactly
and we got to a point right here and I'm
I don't like Black's position I really
position but I thought that the move H5
made your life easier because in a sense
he gave you the G5 square and you
leverage that you square you used it
ahead he played King G7 did you had you
worked out at this point what your
breakthrough might be well I was uh
hoping for a G4 G5 and F4 is always a
move as well at some point uh so I mean
I have a free play I can do that's what
I want to do exactly whether or not you
include Rook H1 yeah lovely and in the
game it was a kind of a it was quite I
was actually hoping for H5 because now I
want to go destruction five idea and I
think it's lovely yeah pink G7
um I think he had to try this and after
Rook G5 yes like C5 although I know that
this doesn't work but I think it's just
so bad and with no time he had to do
something exactly because after King G7
I just got Rook G5 and next Rook comes
as well to C5 right and uh the attack is
Just Deadly yeah yeah it really was a
nice tactical finish at the end I really
liked this touch yeah I mean I I did see
that if I I did see that E5 was possible
to make but yeah you'd already rolled it
out as we enjoyed the yeah and the H6
exactly we enjoyed that nice little
tactic
um like I said you saved your best chest
for the very last game I probably you're
thinking why isn't it double round robin
now I'm ready now I'm in the form how
did you like it
yeah yeah Saint Louis is always nice uh
I had the five black games and four
white so definitely finishing with plus
one is a not a bad result and I did not
lose a single game so definitely I'm
happy with the result feeling good thank
you good luck in your career thank you
very nice very nice as we have uh we do
have a tournament winner as Nicholas
like I said has won his game won the
round we think that Mishra will also uh
with this extra Pawn also likely win
begum where it's bitten it's incredibly
eventful and by the way as we just their
position completely changed apparently
everything everything has changed when
we left this again if Semion wins this
game
that's his first prize that you've been
telling us about all of these uh days uh
first is first he played Rook F1 and
then he just
went back Knight E6 why would you do
that F4 and white said no more attack no
more attack what are you doing this
queen is not uh bouncing to the G3
Square Knight E4 and
in their position in two moves basically
white has achieved just about everything
he possibly could this last move Queen
[Music]
um
it's been working for 1500 years went
ahead material trade so this move give
me your Rook give me this give me this
kind of just anything that forces a
trait like if I can get you to do this
my next move is Rook B6 and that's two
pawns I just don't understand Knight E6
for me it doesn't make sense uh
sometimes you know you're in a situation
where a move night like Knight E6 it
feels a little bit like capitulation
like you're not resisting and it didn't
work out uh well at all for black after
the sequence uh I don't think I think
Queen B7 is much it feels like black
wanted to win the game
if they didn't want to probably be able
to play Knight H3 it's just like
it's the only chance for Armand to share
to Thai for first right right to win the
game by the way I just want to say the
players have made time control and as
I'm looking at the board I'm looking at
the position why aren't I playing E6
oh
that's a everything is meaning yes sir I
well you want to be precise about it too
though right E6 just
that's a killer
I I do believe that there's no chance
for Armand to even draw this game
anymore
no no it feels like we won't have any
playoffs after all none uh actually it's
funny uh this feels like a puzzle Rush
kind of moment what do you think do you
play Queen takes F7 checked here
would you play Queen takes episode I
think I would
yeah why not yeah why not okay let's see
why not take take check the sugar fade
no no check the certified right
then what would you how would you
perceive exactly if I play Bishop takes
uh Queen has to go back right
yeah because you're threatening and then
you just can play Rook a bomb that's the
yeah no this is the best way Rook A1 uh
I wrote Rook A1 funny thing is that it's
writes resistance
ah nice so it does feel like E6 could
win the game on the spot and it looks
like his time but uh he will win the
game for sure but what a spectacular
finish in these Championship rounds that
the winners would win the tournament by
winning the final the the ninth and
Final Round some young there as we see
on screen carefully considering the move
E6 as well as Queen B7 uh that that was
my instinctual gut move just because I
want to play Bishop takes f8 and one to
cement my uh material advantage but E6
looks best yeah but I cannot believe how
wide played we should detune and black
played Knight D6
time scrambles to make fools of us all
right uh by the way how did you like uh
Lucas game you interviewed him and he
was showing you uh what he had intended
it seemed to me like Luca and it
actually prepared he's like oh yeah I
didn't remember and then goes after a
moment he's like yeah actually you can
play a queen I think Queen G6 Knight at
first a line and this is I'm like
interesting right you can't remember you
cannot remember and then and he was like
asking me yeah but you have a like a
game there right I'm like I'm not
telling you
oh he knew your game he he was like yeah
probably the American Cup right I'm like
I'm not dead oh my God and of course he
knows he's my teammate right okay so
there you go uh we do have quite a
number of results once again Nicholas
has won the tournament and he did it in
a spectacular fashion right here this
very nice moment
is like everything came together for
white after the move Knight takes Rook
takes Knight takes Rook to D1
pins the Knight to the queen if the
night moves and it was a very smooth
game by Nichols today
he decided to just to destroy his
opponent basically well in fact because
Nicholas is actually here he's going to
tell us how he won the term and Megan
we're going to lose you and replace you
with this
as uh we're looking at this game of
Mishra for the moment and again Mishra
looks like he's just got this game in
the bag uh one two three four pawns
versus one two three four five and
whites got the better minor piece in
this particular's case
a2a4 Queen E4 all of these moves just
play themselves it's just so nice you
just bring the Knight to a better square
and well it's all it's all one-way
traffic for white at this point
so we expect Mishra
to win and here we are we are we're
honored by the presence of our
tournament winner and Nicholas I mean if
you knew this was going to happen you
would have accepted your invitation even
faster
very well done congratulations thank you
nice tell us what happened today you're
first of all just your mental approach
to today's game I mean at the top it was
tied it was a very exciting going coming
into this realm yeah well first of all I
wasn't expecting to win clear first
because there was a four-way tie right
going into the last round but yeah I
mean I I sort of expected this line by
my opponent okay tell us when uh things
got dicey or good 8283 all standard
I guess D5 is the main move but A3 is a
that was uh my bad sorry uh I did
something incredibly wrong my apologies
there
where are we
[Music]
what did I just do
uh I did something really wrong did you
see what I did I'm not sure I did
something really wrong
uh I clicked
not even sure what I clicked maybe a
previous round
I think we're in a previous Round
Here We Go
here we go okay perfect that was really
crazy I mean normally I make a a mistake
with the mouse it's because I went you
know five moves deep not that I went
four rounds previous uh you were about
to say that uh standard is D4 D5 so you
wanted to get things a little bit off
track early 8283 does it have a history
um I don't know the history exactly but
there was a recent game
um this video against vidit in this line
okay so yeah D5 is Black's best move of
course Knight C3 Bishop B7
and now F3 so you want to sacrifice this
Pawn because you think that the Dynamics
that you get from having the Central
Pawn Duo and you know a Freer play yeah
so taking on C4 Is Not Great already I
think the main line is not a three
Castle H6 castle castle Yeah
castle castle H6 yeah yeah I know
um speedler played Knight H4 which is
pretty interesting
and the
I don't know the game goes on but D
takes C4 by him is pretty ambitious I
suppose
okay
um so yeah I mean I knew the startup
setup is with H3 King H2 and the main
idea is to play Knight H4
right so I did all of these moves
excuse me thank you so you did exactly
what you were prescribed H3 King H2
Knight H4 and you've got your prep on
the board then kind of I mean right I
wasn't sure if I should stick to the
same plan given his
um
five B5 Rook A6 yeah it's a bit unusual
but his Rook can actually be quite
useful along the sixth round yes I saw
it as uh as you say a dual purpose it
useful along along the sixth ring but
also it's defended so I can play B4 in
any kind of Trades I I make B5 B4
potential and also getting out of the
way of the Bishop from yeah yes exactly
so not a bad idea and he did uh
consequently played before actually in
these situations I have no idea if I
should play Knight A4 or Knight E2 but I
mean both of my Nets will be on the rims
and you didn't in principle you know
uh I think every chess player has that
feeling During certain games where you
get this impression that you might
winning a brilliancy you might be
willing for brilliantly like and you
know some chess authors will use your
game as a brilliant or conversely the
worst you might be losing a pregnancy
and then you go to play to move 60s
and then they're going to show you show
an example of this idiot
you didn't want to run it it felt more
natural to keep my night closer to the
action
and not to be the topic of discussion in
the chat how to lose on chess right 92.
okay so you're a pawn down but once
again uh blacks got issues right he
still has to deal with this
I notice also by the way you weren't
anxious well are you anxious to play
Knight F5
she's trying to undermine my center for
the time being so it didn't
I mean I kind of have to play E5 I
thought because I'm a good D5 and he
gets a blockade on the dark squares with
the bishop D6 probably okay and he has
some Knight G4 ideas okay okay uh
because in the game I thought it was I
don't know if this was the moment so
forgive me uh
can he sacrifice a piece yeah he briefly
considered that option but then yeah
just take and then probably take on B4
as well okay a b a b yeah
uh take yeah and I said trade okay
uh I pause for just a moment because I'm
not 100 sure how am I supposed to
recapture but okay
the night yeah what do I what's the body
count I do have three pawns right
yeah and then I thought I'd play Knight
F4 for example okay
wow you know I can resist anything
except Temptation
every fiber of my being but okay D4 is
hanging the the reason I said this is
because in the game it kind of felt a
little bit one-way traffic yeah
and then I'm sitting there saying would
the peace sacrifice have thrown you off
kilter because uh in the game
I already started to really warm up to
your position here I think here you
started feeling good too it definitely
looked nice for a while right
actually you know you're not sure
scoring the full point wasn't that easy
it never is yeah it's a problem right uh
Knight F4 but again you know it
these guys kind of feel like they're
stuck in mud a little bit and these guys
look like they're you know potentially
playing okay it went Bishop G5 the
moment he played G6 I thought something
was wrong now it felt like yeah yeah I
spent
probably about half an hour 9 H5 to
induce G6 right but it looks a bit
strange to just
yeah just to lose a Tempo like right
uh because it just felt that blacks
position got too loose it just it
and tell me when you think you made a
mistake or when it was yeah so here
I'm not sure if he missed that after
1995 have Rook D4 or because otherwise
my punches just look a little uh
targeted or I mean
yeah so rookie 8 I was kind of expecting
this move okay yeah and then another
decision was whether I should play Queen
of Europe right
and you decided
on Queen F1 because yeah also keeping an
iron
C4 and F7 but you know with Queen F3 I
can triple in the file if I remove my
Bishop from right C1 so right again much
like 94 92 I wasn't sure which one to go
for exactly exactly it's terrible you
can sit there at the board and you can
make these compelling Arguments for
Queen F3 and you know like you just said
triple
and then you do you mentally flip a coin
or did you just kind of come to the
conclusion that actually Queen was
better on F1
it looked
better to have the bishop open
um
and yeah I
keep keeping an eye on C4 as well so
yeah it can't be that bad right again
just tell me when you think life was
just
terrible
because here again it just felt like to
us we were looking for forcing winds at
this point we did we weren't even we we
didn't think there was a way for black
to resist in the game there wasn't
resistance either did you see any way
for him to resist I missed this rookie 5
move actually because I thought I had
Bishop F4 when I went for this line just
yes but he has some tricks with Rook F5
probably in Bishop C7 Queen C7
okay and if I take he has some Rook F2
check and it's not great not what you
wanted exactly so you would more or less
gotten here in your mind and you thought
Bishop F4 but then you could you found
in the game this nice switch that you
did have Queen D4
probably he should have tried F6 okay
and then he wanted Bishop F4
not sure I was also looking at Queen C5
yeah Queen C4 Queen C5
and he's sort of holding on for now but
it's very very loose
yes
anytime we got the Rook to E2 we were
unhappy we thought that
somehow well I was sorry I was starting
queen of Fade with Queen C5 oh sorry
you're certain yes
okay that's a sneaky move you got me
there no question so Queen D4 Queen E7
nice move rookie one
and you're just losing a piece at these
points exactly and we weren't sure we
were guessing what was the times towards
the end were you both in a little time
trouble yeah we both had one minute for
10 moves right we we couldn't see from
our monitors and uh yeah I mean the way
he played in Vienna also made it easier
I thought she could have taken on D5
with a knight
just right here yeah 95.5
7 Rook H5 sort of trying to hold on yeah
it's completely losing but right at
least he has a better version than the
game right yeah still losing for sure
but uh what you got in the game with G7
Champion
sounds good huh pretty good
if you already got your speech prepared
for tonight's uh oh is there going to be
a speech right oh yeah oh they're great
oh yeah you're required you win
tournaments you got to give a speech you
got to thank the commentators first and
foremost
your trainers your family but no
seriously it feels good it's a nice
tournament right yeah definitely what's
next on your agenda uh I'm playing a
tournament
um in Silicon Valley
yeah what's the show uh
Swiss it's just a Swiss okay so yeah I'm
excited for that and it's also the first
time I crossed 2600
our congratulations all around really
really well done Nicholas thank you
thank you as we have a champion first
place 6 000 bucks
dinner's on him tonight
Nicholas is picking up the tab everybody
[Laughter]
I'm not so sure about that ah welcome
back Bingham uh nice nice game there and
as
for his uh absolutely the a group
crosses the 2600 barrier now that is
awesome when I crossed the 2600 barrier
I want to say that we had a world
champion
in his world champion was Anatoly karpov
and Anatoly carpa had won everything he
just wins all the tournaments Linares
tillberg
all of these events in Yugoslavia and
there would be the all of these events
in the Soviet Union he just won
everything
and he was the world champion
dominating the world of Chess and he was
26.70.
that was his rating and he was heads and
shoulders above everybody I had crossed
let's say 26 35
and you know
we thought there was a gap
you know now they're 2800s
it's like he just crossed 2600 I'm like
oh I remember
actually a new generation is getting
stronger and stronger oh no question
about it now we have like because you
because of you guys actually right
what your experience the wisdom
absolutely
search for
trying to get in as many accolades as I
can here but no for me what I think the
huge differences uh with today's
generations and actually two things and
it's a factor of the computer of course
but the first and foremost
is just the information I know this
sounds weird but the databases of games
today you have a million games or more
and you you got all of the resources
we fought I mean really really hard just
to get the bulletins of the rounds there
is a documentary about Boris Golf and
yeah one of my favorites just players
yes I like him as a person too right so
I was watching the documentary where he
said that there were times when he was
fighting for this like uh journals or or
books and then he was like letting the
library really know that hey I want one
can you please keep one for me exactly
exactly can you imagine the situation
right now
that's exactly what I fought for and and
it was probably much harder for me he is
coming from belarusa is coming from
Seattle and I went to the Seattle Public
Library and literally this massive
Public Library it was a wonderful public
library in Seattle
uh probably had about 30 chess books
many of them were from the 30s 40s and
50s here I am playing in the 70s
I couldn't get anything so so first and
foremost it was this information we got
all of these tools which is absolutely
absolutely fantastic as the first thing
then the second thing I experience and
I'm sure I wasn't the only one I was 13
years old playing chess
nobody wanted to play me I mean nobody
wanted to play me why well they really
didn't want to beat me yeah but they
especially didn't want to lose to me
either
not to play at all exactly yeah so but
today thanks to the chess engine you
have an opponent 24 hours a day the
engine never says no online you could
play all the time 24 7 basically so
right so the information and the
competition also in in human level as
well like past experiences like we learn
from them and then you guys pass it uh
to us and then for example now you're
teaching me right something sure telling
me some things that's how we can get the
information faster and more efficient
exactly because some things you guys had
to sit down and learn yourselves now
you're just telling us and we are saving
so much time on that absolutely uh let's
go to this huge game of Semion uh all he
well all he needs With Victory he wins
the championship and we think he's got
it he's very close there's no way I I
would be shocked if he messed this up
there's no way for him to mess this up
you would be I know are we so blocked
but like it was a different situation
yes right here how can you do that you
should try really hard yeah you should
find the worst moves like Bishop E5 is
an
isn't it that is one of the moves I I'm
a pond grapper so I was thinking takes
takes in Bishop E5 yeah I think I think
Samia is thinking that Bishop E5 is more
precise
I think his idea is that if you take on
E5 I take on F7 and then Queen E5
Checkmate yeah that's exactly right that
he definitely has that inner meso
um
weird that's weird for me because okay I
would think that after Queen E5 check
I'm winning as white yeah but I would
think to myself well
can't I
take the pond first can I have a better
winning position yeah right between C5
you can be winning but how are you
winning not here but like without taking
on F7 but how are you winning that
because now you need to find precise
moves to win the game okay
um okay so Queen C5 Queen C5 check so
takes takes something like this that's
right yeah I I know that your position
is better well of sure better for sure
but we're looking at uh forcedures
A1 is most probably just winning the
game okay he well now why isn't our
system updating I have a very hard
problem yeah sir you got lucky I know
because you have me now so so he did
Play Bishop E5 correct yeah and then E7
Rook E8 was played as well so he did
yeah
it was played he's just taking his time
to make the mail this is on the ball
yeah this is on the board oh my okay so
Rook Avon is just rookie Fe Avon is
which is winning the game why is it just
winning the game though isn't it oh
never mind no F6
Rook a a king F7 wait we talked about it
but I forgot that King E7 is taking wait
a sec hold on are you winning no he just
played a move like Rook to D7 or
something
and H
Stakes are we missing something
yeah
it's weird because you cannot play Rook
D7 because my work is on D3
yes sir what was played uh it's hard for
me to tell oh he took on F7 and King h8
was played
like takes here
yeah it was and then th8 okay A7 and H5
I think that's wait why didn't you take
enough Summoners The Rook
is
um
so you're saying he took the pawn yeah
and then instead of Rook takes F7 he
played King h8 he played Rook E7
actually maybe our broadcast uh maybe
our transmission was wrong maybe he took
on F7 indeed and then played Bishop E5
which is really four five six six yeah
and then they've reached the same yeah
they've reached the position but through
a proper move order I would say yeah now
it makes sense yeah now it definitely
makes so H5 and now we look for uh just
the winning
um moves here so the idea behind H5 is
the desirable Rook E8 black is still
resisting us with the move King we
talked yesterday as long as you do your
best to resist maybe some uh something
guys
it's not that easy for example in this
position
if I play Rook D7 and
Graphics yeah you
he played Rook A1
just
this position after H5 he played Rook a
one king each someone was playing eight
seven I suppose I'm just going to double
I love why do I I actually already made
a draw so he's not catching uh up to
letters too most probably we can uh say
that samion is gonna grab clear first
and
Andrew Hong is clear second
because akshat is not catching that's
right six points I think we do by the
way have Rook A7 on the board yeah King
H7 Rook a
one salmon yes and this feels like it's
really going smoothly now uh I I see
even a Checkmate that just put some
thing on the board I was going to go how
do I do it
um I don't know something like this this
this this
that's a key Checkmate oops
it is indeed so yeah I see that after
Rook A7 you're just prepping the move
Rook on
E7 to E8
and you can say yeah it's like Ah that's
what happens when you play 96 right then
use
you just blame yourself I didn't I take
a draw or at least try Knight H3 exactly
it's a very painful Moment Like painful
realization that you could do better
right you knew better but you didn't do
that exactly
and we see here uh those Death Rows
those moments when you just say oh
oh why am I uh why did I wake up this
morning
um well two extra pawns I think uh
dominating position by the way I would
and I'm I'm not kidding I would actually
consider uh grabbing a third yes or
funny thing yes I play for example Rook
d8 I'm sorry yes right
as well you're not uh text
it's just so winning like here it is so
winning he might resign I would not be
surprised no I think he actually played
Rook 8-1 we'll put that on the board
so rookie King H7 Rook A7 let's say just
what you said Rook here and something
along those lines of what you're saying
is that uh anytime you get to pick up
this bishop unfortunately you cannot
avoid that pin no in the end of the day
pins are always bad I told you already I
hate being pinned I those Eternal pins
where you know your Rook is on your
opponent's Rook is on the eighth Rank
and you've got a bishop on f8 and he's
got a bishop on H6 your king can't move
your Bishop can't move and you have a
piece that's defending it's just
horrible it's like talking you feel like
you're handcuffed you're tied up there's
nothing you can do and you feel this
physical helplessness
um physical pain
my friend Jeremy Silman says you know
chess is hard and then you die
that's so depressing but he's so right
too oh my god oh how hurtful is that to
play H4 like this H 5 H4 on the board
it's a funny story but like my sister
told me she used to play chess as well
she's like I can see my position she was
playing a game with another
like Uzbekistan National Championship
something with another girl she's like I
can see my positions winning and then my
opponent has a trick but my opponent
started to pack her things literally she
was putting everything right so her idea
was to trap my sister she's like okay
yeah like oh it's all done yeah it's
over let's get going all this is one
last trip
and then her idea look like some just
wears are so tricky they're like they
will do everything into it until the end
right and I find it like so what
happened so what happened with your
sister no of course she won the game but
she didn't fall for the Trap yeah
but this um gives a lot of like insights
of how chess players
do and others like depending on the
airplane for example maybe he's just
making this move like okay I don't have
anything I'm just playing it out and
everything maybe he has something in
mind exactly he's trying I always love
it they have these interviews at the
Grand Chester so it doesn't matter you
know Magnus comes out you know you know
what happened today and he said well my
position was terrible and here it comes
they always say and at this moment I
wanted to resign they never resigned
right then they saved the game here I
wanted to resign so here with the move
H5 H4 I wanted to resign and then he
never resigns it needs somehow magically
and it's funny that almost all like top
chess players always say yeah I wanted
to resign I'm like dude then why aren't
you too right exactly get out of here
with that I want I think it's just very
irritating for their opponent who sees
the interview most probably right you
will catch it somewhere and then hearing
that it just hurts even more it's
psychological I know just like yeah last
last twist I just uh a couple of things
uh two very quick stories one from my
own experience and I can share another
one uh so I was a young boy I was
1970. so I'm 13 years old I'm playing in
my first U.S open my first U.S just
imagine dark hair that's all the real
difference
I I'm playing in my first U.S open and
I'm in the B group so it means I have
some really fantastic 16 90 rating or
something like that right
and I'm playing board 270
nice elderly gentleman there big smile
on his face very happy beautiful teeth
by the way really really really nice
smile and the game goes on and the smile
turns into a grimace
yeah and then we get into time trouble
the guy has a glass of water he takes
his teeth out and he puts him in the
water right next to him
with his teeth they've been smiling at
me for four hours and now suddenly
they're in this glass of water boy I I
mean I literally played the the time
trouble with my hand yes hands like that
then there was a famous it was called
the pipe game the pipe game
um bird the
um I think it's Amos bird so
he's got a situation we just got I'm
sorry yes sir yeah we just got results
H4
indeed he resigned and look how uh nice
he is to his opponent Armand lost the
game but he still smiled and then
congratulated his opponent as we have a
champion champion in the house our
congratulations is
the winner of the big group of Summer
chess classic congratulations and he's
grabbing four thousand dollars as well
so just to I'll finish this quick story
hopefully Simeon uh I will enjoy uh
his victory and come and share it with
us so uh
bird has this situation that he wants to
sacrifice at night he wants the night is
attacked the night is attacked and he
wants to play this move King H1 if you
take the Knight then you're gone so if I
play the move King H1 if I play the move
King H1 he'll go wait a minute the
knight's under attack you're an idiot
I'm gonna take the Knight why would you
do that oh I see the combination I the
combination got it so what does bird do
this is fantastic so in those days you
were allowed to smoke on the board and
the people who use the pipes they have
all of these tools for the bowl that
burns the tobacco they have this tool to
pack the tobacco and they have this
other tool to clean out the Ash and they
have this other tool to clean the pipe
he's got all of these tools
so he's preparing his pipe bowl and he
goes and he knocks over his King
as he's doing his thing he just knocks
over his King opponent says touch move
you've touched your king No Limit look
I'm just making my my my my part no no
no look you touched your king
so he moves his King and then the
opponent triumphantly takes the Knight
and taco he wins
that is upon enough for the Trap he
purposefully knocked over his King so
the opponent would say touch move
eh that's all right
someone like that I grew up with someone
like that
he was so tricky he taught me how to
play chess and then we had like small
tournaments at home because my all of my
siblings actually play chess so he would
do everything to trap me like there were
moments he cried like literally he's
like oh my God I forgot my queen and
then I would just grab it like eagerly
I'm like yes finally I am winning him
for the first time and then he would
just like take away take away the tears
from like wipe it away and he's like
making a move and then I can see that
next move is a Checkmate right
the final position by the way uh there
is that problem that you you don't want
to trade because I and if you do take
there is that made right there on the
board you don't have time
to do anything and that was why with
this move Rook on e70 E8 uh black gave
it up you take the take the bishop I'll
take the Rook thank you and that will be
the game so our congratulations and I
think we've got the final standings now
maybe um
yeah we can actually uh tell the people
what they won because of all of those
standards now actually it's not as easy
exactly Knight D3 check but it's going
to be a long game for sure because
probably A4 I will exchange the pawn
somehow
A4 here but it's all about this guy
right this guy just wins the game I get
to go King F3 I get to go King E4 and I
get to go g
G3 to G6
F4 King comes to E4 G4 G5 it must be
winning right there's really not too
much in it and uh this is one of those
uh
this is one of those terrible terrible
endings in the sense that the defender
has nothing yeah they're they just need
to play that out it's like suffering for
nothing right but you usually what I
want to say is that when you're
defending a bad position you've got some
counter chances there's something
there's no counter chances here oh I
know I'm gonna set up a fortress yeah
there's no Fortress to set up there's
nothing to do as the night will come to
D3 dominate The King will come to E4
that will in tune the king to make sure
that it has no moves and then the pawn
will just go to the G of the board so
yeah it may take you 20 moves but you're
winning Victory is inevitable here for
uh Mishra and like you were saying he
started badly
but uh he's catching up yeah this uh
second half a he's not a good win I
remind you like he was overwhelmed and a
lot of emotions joy and
like during the Juniors especially and
then a lot of energy was spent on that
that's why like starting the tournament
was kind of hard even though he had a
week but sometimes it's not enough
exactly and now it feels like he is
recovered totally and he's playing his
best yeah I know I and I know exactly
that feeling played in U.S championships
where at the end of the tournament you
just felt like drained and all you
wanted to do was crawl back to your
hotel room and just go to sleep for the
next three days I mean it was a you're
an exhausted mentally physically
emotionally we played 13 Rounds last
year and then I had the horrible like
tournament plus I was doing school work
and everything the US championships last
year was a pandemic catch-up where you
had people who had qualified and then
the tournaments hadn't taken place and
so and we had another qualifiers yeah so
it became a 14
list of rest stays and then coming
earlier going it just takes them almost
took a month right of like you prepare
for it it's so draining and plus you
play a horrible tournament
I was exhausted I didn't want to do
anything after for a month I just wanted
to stay some like somewhere in a hotel
room my room just don't bother me
exactly but it's funny to hear your
complain and I think to yourself myself
oh you guys have it so easy you know
when I was your age no uh my my
tournaments were
16 players and even sometimes 18 player
fields around Robins but we also had
what we call the Germans so the games
weren't finished in a single day
sometimes they took two and sometimes
even as many as three days and the
tournament seemed to last forever like
and it was like candidates before it was
like candidates yeah I'm just so strong
and so long 53 candidates
and also we have the winner of the big
group which is Samuel yes and he's going
to be yeah he's gonna be with us in a
second exactly and will
pick things right up
as Simeon is in the house gonna lose
bacon you know but it's not the worst
thing that ever happened
well yeah it's kind of bad it's kind of
bad but not the worst thing and uh well
we
we will get ourselves started here as uh
well we have a we have a
dragon on the board not the the not not
the most common uh guest in tournaments
these days but first of all hearty
congratulations thank you thank you very
very nice with that how does that feel
it's incredibly incredible sexually yeah
it was such a dance tournament I think
all of my games were incredibly tense
double aged and it's such a relief to
finally you know get it over with and
win right so it's very very nice take us
through the game and tell us your
mindset I mean because it's at the top
there it was very very tough round you
knew coming in
um the tournament you you can control
your own destiny to a degree but then
you don't want to you don't want to
spoil your event by going crazy that's
Victory right yeah no I was going into
this round that was okay with the draw
okay
um he was trailing half a point behind
so I understood that he would play for a
win of course so I tried to play solid
and just generally I had the you know
experience playing around Robin and in
the last round
I was uh leading the tournament by half
a point right and uh I started playing
for for a win almost lost
and all of my competitors lost as well
yeah the lesson that I learned is that
you know you should always be happy with
the draw a few leads in the tournament
exactly so Bishop C4 Bishop C4 yeah
Queen A5 I mean if he doesn't go into
Mainline Dragon but it's kind of a nice
opening to play if you need to draw I
think because it's so forced okay
um Castle
three
Edition D7 Knight D3 did you
correctly guess that your opponent might
play the game yeah so his main opening
is actually first E5 okay but I didn't
even prepare it because again the
tournament situation required that he
also played really hard to win exactly
and I mean some people don't really do
that some people are okay with the
drawing such case but I saw that last
round in round nine in this tournament
he played sir last year in round nine of
his tournaments he played the purse we
saw yeah yeah so I understood that he
won't be playing E5 you know I I played
the perk it was my main defensive weapon
but then there was a chess book which
said the perk was bad
and you know what I did stop reading the
book
I like the burger
yeah Knight B3 tell us about that though
um it's just the first line of the
engine okay nothing to the complex going
there I mean the idea is kind of to put
the pawn on A5
um pretty straightforward nothing not
much going on grab a little space on
that side yeah Knight D3 queen queen d8
A4 okay I mean I think the
well it's not such a common line so I
wouldn't call it the main move but the
mode that I guess comes to minus Knight
A5 it looks logical removing this type
but maybe he didn't want to create he
wanted to keep attention to play for a
win so B6
probably going to say five Bishop F1
okay there is no deep logic behind my
moves I was just trying to play quick to
take the time because yeah that was my
plan pretty much and play solid
Bishop A6 Queen D2 okay
um
it feels like you have a little bit
something there it's a little Annoying I
I don't know what it is but I feel
uncomfortable as black yeah absolutely
the other thing is I don't have a clear
plan as well I mean I was looking at
something like H5 and I was thinking oh
you know I didn't have the next move
either okay but I was fine with it I
just tried to play fast and let him
think okay not before
okay
um
yeah I mean how do you create a weakness
over there exactly and then
open my Rook not nothing not much going
on very intuitive move
um everything looks very solid I was
looking at something like 98 C4 wow okay
and I think throughout the game these
ideas were quite common right right but
I don't think there is anything I can do
well anything through C1 or maybe keep
the other Rook not sure but I don't
think he has enough compensation right
um so Queen C7 again very logical
8xb6 8xb6 and here I was faced with a
big choice
um I think his main weakness as
ironically is the Knight on B4 it's
hanging in mid-air and it doesn't have
it's not protected exactly
and I have multiple ways of attacking it
so I can go for example I can move this
either way so I need to protect the
discovery like Knight B5 yeah I can also
go Queen D4 okay the problem with Queen
G4 is there's this Knight D5 right I
actually never mind about C2 but yeah
the problem within principle with Queen
D4 is he can actually bundle that
I was looking at Rook C1 for 20 minutes
in order yes yeah but the 95 I think
just completely kills it yeah so I
played Knight D4 the idea being to move
this Knight away yep take the C2 Queen
B7
and
I think I could also I could play Rook
A3 just keep the pressure keep the
position very complex
awesome also it just feels uh some young
that uh I like this move Rook A3 because
Rook B3 could also be really annoying
exactly oh my gosh I mean at some moment
you know you can imagine black
desperately playing E5 and D5 and you
know Rook C3 I don't know Rook C3 Knight
E4 because you start to get this feeling
like uh I'm I'm on the back foot
yeah I agree um I think he has to go has
has to do something drastic like E5 yeah
drastic I think otherwise yeah it would
be three rubies it is very dangerous
exactly the problem is the problem is I
just calculated this line and I didn't
want to go for okay three didn't want to
spend more time okay 91 is a funny move
because uh I mean it's kind of a move
back but the Knight has to be Creed ic6
and then be space six right uh by the
way just a quick question for you in
this position you you mentioned before
these ideas of Knight take C2 Knight
takes E4 you considered them but you
found go ahead if you were playing yeah
C2 Knight c294. again I'm thinking
drastic and desperate right but it's not
enough compensation I don't think so
again I was going into this game
thinking if I get a solid position even
if it's not better I'm fine so looking
at that I thought everything's protected
I'm a piece up even if there is enough
compensation okay I will never lose this
so I was fine I was all right yeah fair
fair
um so 96 96 Bishop A6 28 it's a funny
line I underestimated that I thought
there was no way he could be fine right
but I think turnout he was I mean
remarkable yeah and the game was very
very complex after that I was very happy
with that not so happy you know an hour
later
[Laughter]
so Bishop State I don't think works but
I guess for the sake of time we can
skip that Knight C3 just protecting the
E4
Rook as well as protecting the rook and
now you want to Munch The Exchange yeah
yeah and F3
I just wanted to grab this B6 spawn
good thinking yeah the training is
working but uh I underestimated this
this weakness because it's really you do
have a G3 Square issue yeah yeah and
that's what happened in the game later
on actually I started thinking about
these games in the like Hedgehog where
yeah why has they put on F3 and black
just blast the sensor open and with D5
yeah and Away you go what can take Five
Pawns on the queen side it doesn't
matter you can't get exact yeah so Queen
B8 Queen F2 Knight D4
it should be five and E5 and D5 is
coming so E5 Knight B3
Bishop takes Knight takes and he played
Rook C8 maybe he could play D5 straight
away very very complex I I I actually
don't know if that was good for me or
not right here this was our main line
because we anticipated him playing E5
and D5 and we thought D5 Queen D2 was
your intention we weren't sure
um here you mean with Rook on C8 on d8 I
think with the Rook Geo now I'm not 100
I'm sure either here I was going to play
Rook A4 sorry no you're right Rook A4
was Our intention that's right yeah yes
um
I think I'm I'm fine I'm just not sure
how much I black cares about this Pawn
like I can probably but again I was
thinking about the all of these games
were black just like the inside yeah
like Rook C8 and it's really nice okay
I'm a pawn down but you've got some
weaknesses yeah yeah now looking at that
I actually don't know what's what move
to make sure
um uh you were you're gonna cross that
bridge if your opponent uh forced you
yeah he didn't play that he played Rook
C8 I think that also makes a lot of
sense he actually told me after the game
that he blundered something which we
will get to in a moment okay so they
used to attack the C2 pawn and wait for
one move and then play D5 okay Rook C1
D5
as you suggested but the Rook is not on
C on d8 anymore so exactly
um you protect D3 simultaneously as well
yeah yeah so the knights Rook C4 I think
very importantly I have is Knight A3
that's actually in C initially
speaking of that I think something like
B5 could also be interesting not sure if
black has enough uh I'm not sure if it
works out tactically I think it
shouldn't I have C3 and everything right
but it's just kind of like a model line
of something like take Stakes
I think this could be quite quite
interesting
maybe you don't want to get involved in
these lines there's some Bishop C5 thing
that you might want to prefer yeah right
oh Mike takes C4 and Bishop C5 yeah
something of this nature yeah that's a
little bit more than yeah letting his
Knight hop hippity hop yeah so you play
D4 right I was shocked just took on D4
because I thought it was just a bomb
blunder turned out to be a very
interesting position I think he had lots
of compensation okay cool that I
underestimate it so takes Bishop F4
takes
and Knight H5 right suddenly I realized
that I didn't know what is it what to do
and even though he said that he did
blunder I think he was kind of a lucky
blunder because yeah sometimes you had
those right here the move Bishop D2 was
a kind of a stunner because I think our
Focus had been on Bishop D6 and E5 we
anticipated you if he moves as a rook it
doesn't really yeah we weren't really
sure the problem was Bishop H6 that I
didn't like you didn't like Bishop A6
yeah oh oh so I have you have to
sacrifice in exchange now Queen takes D4
Queen takes D4 something like that right
probably I was actually looking through
K7 okay easy six Knight takes this is
the riding the tiger actually I was
thinking of of checking first right
taking I don't know what which score is
the best but say H2 okay
and queen C4
and um oh no sorry not Queen C4 oh yeah
Quincy form sorry I was about to say
this is commentators prerogative our
prerogative is we get to put all the
pieces on pre
and more or less
the players have succeeded in taking
over the commentators chaos uh this is a
mess
[Music]
so I mean my first thought was okay I'm
trading the Queens I should be fine but
the more I looked at this the less I
liked it okay because there are always
these Bishop of four ideas with xd6
right so I decided to
um play distribution okay
Rook d8 again I think a very strong move
I underestimated that I just didn't
think he could play so slowly move his
Rook away from the open file right but I
think once he does that it becomes very
double-edged
and the game went Rook a seven queen bee
queen E7 and now yeah that was the whole
idea you wanted to trade Queens neither
for very strong again I think
very very strong I didn't see this okay
Rook F1 I think our Focus for what it's
worth I was King F1 strangely enough
yeah uh sidestepping both Knight H3
which we thought was a very serious
threat as well as Knight E2 something
like Knight H3 Queen C6 yeah and this is
yeah okay now it starts to get messy and
the clean goes to H2 yeah that's true
it's good so you went Rook effort into
F1 flash it was definitely possible I
thought we we thought you would play
King H1 exactly yeah I think gtx62 loses
I think yeah so King H1 I don't think
has anything better than Retreat okay
and uh
yeah yeah maybe there was something
better but I was fine with that
he played 96 I think also a very
interesting move potentially F4 I think
D3 was very interesting
he didn't do that
um I think if I don't take this phone
becomes very dangerous like something
like C3 it just lives yeah yeah this
Pawn is uh like you say dangerous Pawn
Yeah so takes and Rook D3
just so double-edged so sharp I have
I don't know where where I should put my
Bishop um right
um let's just see uh because uh we we've
got our uh dinner our closing ceremony
coming up at this moment we thought that
you were dominating yeah I think so at
this point it's pretty much uh over and
uh
his last chance so you think his last
chance was here that he had to play D3
after F4 I think so yeah I think yeah I
think absolutely five I'm a healthy bun
up my pieces are better his Bishop is
bad so I think that was last mistake
after that I think it's pretty much over
it and once again your judgment after D3
was
um
I thought it should equalize but I
didn't think I I should have more really
yeah okay I mean I'm not sure because I
had we were both in time trouble right
um but yeah I didn't think I let's put
it this way I thought this compensation
was very strong whether or not it works
out tactically I don't know maybe
there's a world in which I just win
right but I thought that was dangerous
especially in time travel right
Champion yes very nice congratulations
once more go and celebrate and we will
celebrate with you as the closing
ceremonies coming up thank you so much
for having me I will thank you and there
we have it everyone uh the uh summer
chess classics coming to go coming to a
close with just one game remaining and
that is uh the Mishra versus
darouche game and when we left it it
looked to us like it was completely
winning for Mishra and our judgment
Remains the Same this is completely
winning
and Michelle did bring
it's completely winning uh begum yeah
because Mishra did what you suggested
E4 yeah and then it feels like we are
gonna push the Palm push the baby one of
the things that uh you should always be
I want to say mindful about when you're
pushing the pawn of the board
lead the pawn with your king in other
words play the move King G6
thank you and then G4 let's get your
king uh on the promotion on the
promotion
exactly it feels like he can literally
read your mind yeah well one of the you
know I had this
taser moment it was 2016. I was in Baku
and it was the
um Captain for the US Women's team and
it was the last round the women had
played fantastic we played everybody
India China Russia I mean we just played
all the top teams
and
um uh Anna zatonski
she has a completely drawn ending with
Tanya
all she has to do it's a real component
game all she has to do is bring her King
up the board and escort her Pawn instead
she put her Pawn in front of the king
too far and King got cut and we lost the
game and the match was tied two to two
and it was like the last game to finish
nearly fell off the stage totally
curable you lost your mind I feel sorry
it must be suffer it must be we suffered
and also by the way we shared it even
better King G6 Bishop of Fate King F6
and there is no way to protect E5 boom
true
I think Misha is just getting the game
and tarish is about to resign from the
body language you can see that exactly
he is just making the last move it feels
like Bishop isaban check he did check
King F5 and Jerusalem wolf
no move
Bishop d8 but okay I think we play G4
here I think you can't even take on E5 I
think I know but yeah he's a pond
grubber good man now he takes E5 can you
C5 G4 the problem is that you cannot
attack the Knight Chase it it's just
yeah
if you take on E5 King takes king c46
sorry you went to way too fast Utah go
ahead okay we do not have the most so
okay yeah
six
Knight takes E5 it did good D4 right and
then he did
yeah Bishop C7 yeah I'll be my new is
about to play G5 I believe the problem
is that this doesn't work because I am
way ahead yeah he played it's not even a
race it's not even a race
[Music]
Queen and then
let's go with it exactly for now we have
this position on the board
and reaching for a new score sheet you
know sometimes some players play until
the scoresheet and then just resign on
the 60th move or the end of the score
sheet because it's they're lazy they
know oh the position is completely lost
why I would waste
and there is there is a weird thing when
you're close to underscore but
you're losing you play that out
right
I have a feeling Darius is ready to
design sure I think in moments like
these uh I think a lot of Grandmasters
get lost in what happened earlier in the
game and they're just thinking about
troubles past it's just
it's just players upside
right exactly because it's just a great
feeling to end the tournament with a
victory here we go he did resign and
then we don't have any uh
yeah but at such moments we also like to
kind of do a uh badge of honor we go
down the list of the participants
absolutely how they did because you
explained to us so very very nicely uh
you know that everybody's going to get a
prize you would say everybody's going to
get a prize so what we're going to do is
we're going to go down the list of
players but
in Reverse we're gonna go uh from 10th
to first let's start with group a
perfect so unfortunately darus lost his
game and finishes and finished
unfortunately the tournament was three
points right and last place and we have
tie for eight which is abhimanyu Mishra
in Krishna and Sasuke puran with Serena
Health points and we have Thai four six
pranoff
and we have typhosa fourth which is
Benjamin bulk with five points and we
have time for second ranak satwani and
John Burke with five and a half points
and we have a clear winner of the
tournament solo
first first Nicholas Grandmaster Nichols
Theodore six thousand dollars with six
and a half points and six thousand
dollars our congratulations to Nicholas
now do the same thing but tell us about
the B group
big group Justin Wang got the last place
with two points and al-shan muradabadi
with uh nine with two and a half points
and eight places Alexander landerman
with three points and sevens is Luca
buddhistal which was four and a half
points he gets to fifty percent thanks
to his last round game good win yeah and
we have three-way tie for fourth with uh
Armand mccallion taboration but suren
Brandon Jacobson with five points and we
have clear third action Chandra with
five and a half points and second Andrew
Hong with six points and we have the
winner of the tournament Simeon lamaza
of this six and a half points who is
grabbing for the thousand dollars as
well our congratulations congratulations
to the winners it was wonderful and we
have a photo of all the people that made
our broadcast possible I'm not talking
about us
people thank you so much
because of them we are here yes right
talking right we wouldn't be here
exactly uh in the bay we're not going to
call on the minute from Orange
We're not gonna go but we do have more
chess coming up let's just give a shout
out to chess nine Alex yeah we're gonna
have it from September 7th to tens and
we are gonna have Fisher on them chests
of course we are starting from the
ultimate moose and then we are switching
to Rapid which is 2 20 plus five seconds
it's gonna be an exciting tournament
with great one of the best chess players
in the world absolutely I have actually
gotten a sneak preview of that roster of
players and it hasn't been disseminated
yet but I've got to tell you do mark
your calendars everybody because that is
going to be really really fun and
feature
I'm excited to watch absolutely I like
Fisher random and as we close the show
big I really want to say this is the
first time and I really enjoyed working
thank you and the whole team it was
really really nice I appreciate it I
mean uh that just one moment when you
missed the meat and wand that was other
than that you were terrific you also
disappointed me there but other than
that it's terrible I appreciate it yes
thank you everyone thank you so much
everyone for watching and follow us on
our social media and follow the
tournaments absolutely and meanwhile
goodbye and thank you again bye
[Music]
what
happened
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited